there she is look at how calming there's
and Tom they're coming yeah I'm excited
public sidewalk both that's a little
close now I'm scared
[Music]
alright happy we did everybody once a
order I take the people on we're part of
my content Alpha Team and I think the
medic or treat and last quarter we went
with a bowling no no yeah bullying we
did bowling in the neons the restaurant
sounds good times and this year we were
supposed to go tubing but it's what but
then 11 degrees outside you never let me
finish the story okay go you tell the
story of the great oz has to wait to go
to so with the studies people to this
Jimmy restaurants it is very excited and
let's go 11 degrees for our American
friends watching I don't know what that
is but will flash it right here what 11
degrees in the middle of february's 11
degrees Celsius is crazy you gonna have
more fun there anyway let's do it all
right we're here I made a mistake last
time I paid for everybody to go on the
boat cruise which was a lot of fun at
the time before that was the lunch and
the bullying and so we're here we
switched their plans of snow to be
because it's a glorious day i'm in
shorts and sandals but that's been my
seen this winter anyway so it's the same
building you got to get used to the cold
and breaks the coal that makes them
stronger so this place we came to what a
couple weeks ago they have these the
boobs decent the food was really good
but
the real reason to come with these
amazing desserts that they have stock
toast with ice cream and a whole bunch
of yummy and there were four of us and
we couldn't finish it last time and so
I'm expecting some amazing visuals and
for people to really enjoy the time
together come together with family and
Nina said it all up so we appreciate and
love her let's do it we're the first
ones here we got this big table Nina's
excited there's a way for people to come
and fill it up let me show you the menu
let me show you so these are this is a
regular food it's all good ramen dead
what we came for look at that look at
that toast yeah maybe these things is
huge Nina's going to leave super full
Senate % happening which isn't it leads
going thank you folks is going to leave
oh boy expanding anything Alex Monica's
already she's already organized
everything I think like little pod now
I'm wearing so much and thank you all
right I'm wearing out my sweaters and I
got a little powder yes'm you know but
your show back in London give highs on
your shoulders too yeah why not have a
hard day I need to lean on someone I got
my shoulder pads yeah
allegory my Christmas option here we go
so we're going to introduce all the
helpers right now that I've made it here
tonight today we are you doing on
snapchat yes I am here with all the help
[Music]
my name is Lena I am like people
waitress I favorite moves will be famous
to be not nice Jaime watch helping out
great and I love the simple Marcus
mm-hmm Nina and proper square leg off
music / hey all i could do body
hahaha hiring I've been cussing ha ha ha
here and my favorite who is woman's
backwards ya know reduce no it's all
been alright already posted online oh
that's my name is Alex I've been an
instructor for last year and my favorite
move is the body wave I do it all the
time I don't even know Nina love the
soup
[Music]
let's build on yourself okay we still
love you Nina we still love you Nina
what is not I don't want to try it it's
not really good they look really loud
guys they're all gone it is
[Music]
alex is doing this thing oh nice nice
but some preparations dude I'm a grunt
camera sorry so I held our vez más de
Lima's it once they get some feedback so
we look at all the people like engines
come back and dissipated on everybody I
literally just have to make some like
loosen up so balls to thousands of the
semester in my cup it goes back that's
one you get your law degree philosophy
ds9 plus the price you want he hits
another people wrote lots of the
greatest system of great health or
Monica as a lot of fun as good as like
my dancing for very motivated as helpful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I'm excited
oh oh happy birthday to you brands to
[Music]
dancing with a strawberry since idea
strawberry whatever i reuse that i love
the beard of belief focusing on yourself
and being happy what I did you think I
think of my family and over the last
eight years of educating students how
grateful I am and I would never have
imagined myself sitting with all of you
and my one word is belong it was
different for a place where the people
wouldn't judge me when they can I feel
like this I'm part of their family so
the quote says or the cold lows were it
like you don't need money love like
you've never been hurt dance like
nobody's watching and so dang whenever
I'm a CD I'm dancing i feel like
nobody-nobody busy and i hope you feel
like that to all the love i received
from you it's like all the things in
high school and all the awkwardness I've
had in my life it doesn't happen and
whenever I talk to you I would feel that
it's a genuine relationship and i'm
working at tedious because i don't care
about the money i don't care about the
power I don't care about the attention i
scare because it would be something
bigger we're doing something bigger for
ourselves and for other
as in time I see any of the process
students responding to each other and
the light that lights up and the light
that lights up and meet it makes it a
very special place and so thank you so
much for being part of my family and
thank you for letting me be part of your
family your lives anyway and I just it's
incredible and I'm super proud of all of
you and just forward we have here thank
you guys hey Emma cries okay real men
crying all right we're done I'm feeling
full I was getting a feeling I'm ready
for a nap to send up here after your
collar there she is looking up comedy
news man that was insanely feeling good
times though amazing people love the tds
family thank you to Nina for setting it
up to organizing the tubing and then
organizing this in all the chaos went
with it we good job what hope you guys
have an amazing weekend and she need to
believe whatever you want in we'll see
you soon